- You don't know know
everything, all right?
let's just get it right
out there on the table.
Most people's ego's are so inflated
and so fragile that
they won't allow people
to see them be bad at something.
I see every day people with this mentality
that the world owes them something.
Don't say, "Wow, that guy's so lucky."
Say hey, that's a fortunate
dude, he's very fortunate.
- He's an entrepreneur,
innovator, and businessman.
He started the MFCEO
project website and podcast
with a goal to inspire and motivate people
in they're business and lives.
In 2014, he was awarded
Entrepreneur of the Year
by the Secret Entourage Academy.
He's Andy Frisella and here's my take
on his top 10 rules of success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite.
Imake sure to stick around
all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips
and as always if Andy says something
that really, really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
(uplifting symphony music)
- You don't know everything, all right?
Let's just get it right
out there on the table.
I meet so many young entrepreneurs,
they think they know everything,
they want to know everything,
they want to be the best at everything
inside their company and
guys that's just not reality.
Okay, you have to understand,
winning in business
is not about you personally
as the CEO of a company
being the best at every skillset.
Dude, I can't put together graphics,
I can't put together videos, I can't,
there are certain things in my company
that I have no clue on
how to do but that's okay.
You know what my job is?
My job is to go out and
find people that can do that
far better than myself so
that we can win as a team.
And this attitude of
I've got to be the best,
and I've got to win and
I've got to, you know,
and I'm the best at everything
and I know more than you
and blah, blah, blah, blah,
that makes horrible leadership.
Nobody respects that.
Let me tell you what people do respect.
People respect when
you look 'em in the eye
and you say, "Hey, what do you think?"
And then, they give you an
answer and then it's your job
to decide whether or not
on an honest playing field,
whether or not that is
the best thing to do
or whether or not somebody else
has the best thing to do, all right?
And that might be your idea,
it might be another employee's idea,
it doesn't matter as long
as the best idea comes about
and you are able to
decide which one that is.
You guys have to understand
and get over your selves.
Being in business, owning a business,
is not about being right, okay?
I see this also in the same thing
as when people develop
products for themselves
versus understanding what
the market likes, all right?
The same people who I just talked about
that can't accept the fact
that they're not always the best
and that they're not always right
or the same people that
develop products for the market
based upon what they like
and not based upon what the market likes.
And you gusy, all of you
who fall in those groups,
you better learn to do
what I'm telling you to do
or you're going to be out of business.
Because dude big egos, over-inflated egos,
they come from insecurity, all right?
The only reason that
you would act that way
is that if you're actually
insecure about the amount
that you truly know so you
over inflate, puff your chest,
feel like you need to
be right and guess what,
you're usually wrong, your
employees don't respect you,
your peers don't respect you,
and this goes for you people
who are in an office environment
working for another
company, owning a company,
it goes for everybody listening.
You're not always going to be right.
That's okay.
The best leaders in the
world are not the ones
that are the smartest or the
ones that are most right.
They're the ones that can
decipher who's the best
at which job, put in
the right places to win
and then also decide from a humble place
and humble meaning understanding
that you don't know everything,
which idea is going to be
the best for everybody, okay?
That's your job, you're
the captain of the team,
you're the CEO, you're
the captain of the ship.
If you're going to steer
the ship into rocks,
just because you argued
with your first mate
about your path being
right, you're a idiot, okay?
It's okay to not have all the answers,
it's okay to not be right,
it's okay to admit that you weren't right
and in fact, if you want
the respect of your team
and your peers, you will be
willing and able to admit
that you made mistakes, the
minute that you make 'em.
Here's the deal, you want
to know why most people
can never get anywhere in life,
why most people never
live, never experience,
never build, never do anything worthwhile
in life besides being average
and let me know, an average broke.
You know why?
Because most people's egos
are so inflated and so fragile
that they won't allow people to see them
be bad at something.
Okay, let that sink in.
You never done something
before, you expect yourself
to be awesome at it, you
haven't done the work,
you haven't put it the time,
you haven't put in the study hours,
you haven't had the experience
but you expect to be good.
And because you expect
to be good but you know
you're not going to be
good, you don't do anything.
Explain that to me, okay?
You want to be somebody who succeeds,
you want to be somebody
who builds something,
you want to be somebody who
people write books about one day
you're going to have to
be okay with being bad at
for a long time.
When I first started in business,
I didn't even know what
the I was selling, okay?
I remember the first person coming in,
they came in for a product
that I didn't even,
it was called Cell-Tech by
a company called MuscleTech,
they came in, the dude
obviously didn't buy it,
it wasn't our first sale, he
came and asked you about it.
I don't even know what
the fuck it was, okay?
But I didn't care
'cause I was going to
figure it out, all right?
And that's the mentality
you guys have to have.
You have to be okay with
looking like an idiot
for a long time.
And a lot of you guys, you'd
rather be too cool for school,
you'd rather be the cool kids
at the high school lunch table,
than be the person who actually goes out,
takes a leap of faith,
decides they're going
to try something new,
and actually becomes an
expert at it over time.
Guys, you have to be okay
not being good, all right?
Every valuable lesson that
you're going to come across
in your life is going to
come from you something up
A.K.A. failing, all right?
And it, I hate failing
as much as the next guy.
Dude, I probably hold the
record for the most broken
Nintendo controllers on
the face of the Earth
because I hate losing and
if I ever find the person
in Zelda, they're going
to get a knuckle sandwich
'cause I could never beat that game
but that's the point, okay?
I hate to lose but the thing is
is that once you understand
that every time you lose
is an opportunity for you to
not only learn that lesson
but take it a plus one step, okay?
Listen to what I just said, a
plus one step past the lesson,
you'll start to appreciate those lessons,
you'll start to be okay
with not being good at.
Guys, you don't want to be the guy
that we talked about on the
podcast whose 37 years old,
living in your mom's basement,
yelling at her for a hot pocket, okay?
Trolling people on the internet,
you don't want to be that guy.
And if you don't want to be that guy,
you're going to have to understand
that losing is a part
of ultimately winning.
You're going to lose a
lot more than you can win
and when you win, you're
going to figure out
how to get better on top of it.
If you're a true winner, they
don't celebrate their wins.
True winners take the win
and they say, "How could
I have even gotten better?
"How could I ran the score up?
"How could I have won by
twice as many points?"
So you never really feel like you win
and you have to be okay with that, okay?
There's not one thing
that I don't look at in my life
and say man how can I get better at that?
How could I win at that?
How could I run the score up on that?
That's how much I love to win
but I look at every single loss,
I've learned to look at every single loss
as an opportunity of how to win more
and that's what you need too.
You don't look at it like,
hey everybody's going to point and laugh
and they might point and laugh.
I could tell you a list
a mile long of people
who have told me, "Andy,
you still got that
"little vitamin shop?
"Andy, what are you
trying to be Tony Robbins?
"Andy, when you're
going to get a real job?
Those are the same you asking
me for jobs now, all right?
You guys have to understand
that if you are willing to be bad at,
you will have the last
laugh on these same people
that that we're talking about.
I think it's important
for people to understand
at any time you step out of
what's normal in society,
you're going to have criticism.
So many people follow the traditional plan
with no thought whatsoever
as to what they really want to do in life.
They go to school, they go to high school,
they go to college, they get a degree,
they get married, they have kids,
then they wake up at 40 years old
wondering, "What the happened
and where did my life go?"
and when I think about those things,
I think about how much criticism we got
when we started our first company,
when we're only 19 years old
to do all the things that you're
supposed to do in society.
All the people that used to tell us,
"You guys waste your time,
"you need to get a degree,
"you need to get a real job,
"you need to quit wasting
your time with this hobby,"
and those are the same people now that,
they're telling us how
good of a job we did
and how proud we are.
I think about that a lot
and I think people don't realize
that the same criticism that they get
for doing anything outside
of what's considered normal
that goes for anybody that tries anything
outside of what's normal.
And I think people need to realize
that people are going to talk,
they're going to criticize
but what's more important,
what's more important is that you do
what it is you think you need to do
instead of changing your path
for everybody else's happiness
because the reality is
the people who judge you
on doing anything different
are the same people who
can't do it themselves
and I feel like so many
people get so wrapped up
into what other people think
that they ruin their entire lives
living a life that they
don't even want to live.
Everybody's got to find their own path
and you have to realize that
when you get on that path,
you're going to up, you're
going to make mistakes,
you're going to have
bad ups like really bad
but as long as you're willing to learn
and you're willing to take
those as lessons about
and you're smart enough to
not make those same mistakes
over and over and over again,
there's really nothing that you can't do.
I see every day people with this mentality
that the world owes them something
and it's popular now to
talk about entitlement
and everybody deserves and
all these different things
that people like to bitch and cry about
but people come at life
with the wrong attitude, okay,
and and they don't like hearing the truth
and the truth of the matter is this,
the world owes you nothing,
the world doesn't think you're
special like your mom does,
it doesn't think you're
a delicate little flower,
it doesn't care about you.
Now, with that being said
the world doesn't hate you,
it doesn't want you to
fail, it just is, okay?
And I see so many people
going through their life
with this overwhelming feeling of either
a, the world owes me something
or b, the world hates me,
and the reality is it's neither.
And what's common amongst this
group of people that I find
is that both these groups
of people that I find
is that they're missing the understanding
of what it means to be successful.
And let me let me get at exactly
what the cause of this is.
The cause this is their
selfish, they're self-centered,
they're self-focused, they're only worried
about what they see in the mirror
and they go around
through their daily life
trying to manipulate the world in a way
that's going to serve them.
But here's the thing guys,
if that's the way you go through life,
if you go through life
trying to figure out a way
for the world to get you something,
for you to be successful
at the expense of others
or for you to get ahead
at the expense of others,
your success or any success
that you're able to build
or momentum you're able to build
is going to be very short-lived guys
and that's not the right
way to do things, okay?
That's why you see the same people
who make money real fast,
lose money real fast.
That's why you see the same people
who have a little bit of success
and then go back to the way they were
and then they might find a
new quote unquote thing to do
and they make a little bit of money
and they go back to the way they were.
And the problem with this mentality guys
is that it's a mentality
that is not of service, okay?
If you want to be truly
successful in life,
you have to be selfless
and you have to understand
that being selfless
and being of service to other people
is the only true way to
find long-term success.
So many people in life, we
all know these guys, right?
They peaked at high school,
they were prom king,
they were quarterback of the team,
and they go through life and
you see 'em 10 years later
and they're they're sitting
at the bar on a Tuesday
with the male pattern
baldness and they're like,
"Oh bro, back in the day, I was the man,"
and they can't pay their
bills or driving a hooker
and they've turned into a basically
a complete accelerated
version of themselves
which is a douche bag,
and they haven't done anything
with their lives, right?
And we see these people all the time
and the reason these people don't progress
is because they focus on the glory days,
they focus on the things they
have achieved in the past
and they don't let themselves
work towards a better future.
Guys, you have to be
able to look at yourself
and be honest with yourself on this.
If this is you, you have to
stop this behavior, okay?
When you focus on what you did last year
or what you did two years ago
or what you did last month
or the award I wanted the company function
or the sales numbers that I
hit and beat everybody on this
on the squad or whatever,
when you focus on this guys,
that is energy that you could be putting
into actually improving and
focusing on the task at hand
which is today, okay?
Champions don't sulk.
Kobe Bryant doesn't sit
there and talk about
how many MVPs he's won or how
many championships he's won,
no, the up at three o'clock in the morning
practicing every day.
Why do you think he is so great?
He's not great because he's great.
He's great because he puts
the working on a daily basis
and he wins every day.
Too many of you and too
many people in society
fall back on the word luck,
not knowing the circumstances
of someone else's success.
You see big things, you hear big things,
you see people who do big things
and you automatically say,
"Wow that guy's so lucky.
"Wow, she's so lucky.
"Wow, that's so lucky that that happened."
You don't know that, you're assuming that,
and let me tell you how
insulting that sounds
to somebody who has
literally grinded their off
to build something worthwhile, okay?
I'm going to ask you one
thing from this podcast
is to substitute from now on the word luck
for the word fortunate, okay?
Don't say, "Wow that guy's so lucky."
Say, "Hey, that's a fortunate dude.
"He's very fortunate."
There's a big difference
in how that sounds
and what that means and the
metaphysical implications
that stand behind your belief
system when you say that.
When you say, "Oh, that guy got lucky,"
you're telling the universe
and you're telling yourself
subconsciously that you believe
that you are not in control
of your circumstances
and guess what if that's
what you believe, you aren't,
but when you say, "Hey that
guy is very fortunate,"
you know what you're saying?
You're saying, "I believe in control,
"I believe that I am in control
"and I believe that the
consequences of my actions
"are in my control."
And there is a big difference
not just in how you sound
because you sound like a ignorant asshole
when you say people are lucky
they have worked their asses off
but there's a big difference
in what the universe hears
and what will play out when
you use the different terms
of fortunate versus lucky.
So, I'm going to ask you guys
to please stop using the word luck
when you talk about other people's success
and use the term fortunate.
It's going to help you out, it's
going to help out your results,
and it's going to make you
sound like not an asshole, okay?
So, is there, 'cause right now,
I know there's this guy, right there,
he's listening, he's saying,
"But Andy, there is such a
thing as luck, there is luck."
Well no, there's luck,
like when you're riding
your bicycle down the road
and a car hits a puddle of oil
and does a donut and
misses you by an inch,
like we all see on these
videos on Facebook,
that's luck, right?
But going to work every day for 20 years
or grinding your ass off
and then becoming a multi-millionaire,
that's not luck, all right?
That's action and result,
that's action and reaction,
that's not luck, okay?
You weren't there pointing at this dude
who has the life that you want,
you weren't pointing out how lucky he was
when he couldn't pay his bills,
when he got evicted from his house
trying to build this business,
how about when he made
less than what you made
for the first 15 years
holding on to his dream?
You weren't there saying he was lucky.
How about a night when
he's crying to his wife
about how stressed he is
and how hard his life is
and how he's going to be homeless
if he doesn't pick up the results at work?
You weren't there saying, "Oh he's lucky."
You weren't there when he
couldn't take a scholarship
for five years saying,
"Oh man, that dudes really
lucky when his girlfriend left
"because he's a loser."
Or how about when he's working at 2 a.m.?
Or how about when he's working
on weekends and holidays
when you're out celebrate
with your family?
Where were you?
You were saying he's lucky, okay?
You don't know what lucky is
because you're all the story
so quit using the word luck
and start using the word fortunate.
It's going to do you a favor,
it's going to do you a service,
and how you think about results
and it's going to make your what,
it's going to make you sound
like not such an asshole
because there's nothing more insulting
as somebody who grinded their ass off
than when someone says, "He got lucky,"
or "You're so lucky."
It makes me want to punch
you in the eye, all right?
Quit using a word luck,
quit believing in luck
because it doesn't exist
in terms of action reaction
and start believing in work,
start believing in fortunate,
start believing in results
that come from your actions
and when you do that and you
wholeheartedly believe it,
guess what?
That's what starts to happen.
What is the other thing
that kills success?
All right, and it is this mentality guys
especially for you guys who are employees
looking to create value amongst
yourselves within a company
and some business owners do
this too, believe it or not,
but they have the mentality
that they're going to show up,
they're going to put in their time,
they're going to do
the bare minimum, okay,
of what is expected of them
and what they are paid for.
So, there's a difference here
that I wanted I want to delineate
for you guys, all right?
There are people who show up
to work and hide in the corner
and don't do and expect to keep their job.
Then, there are people
who show up to work,
put in the effort, do
what they're paid to do,
and then go home and talk
about how great of a employee
or an asset they are to the company.
All right guys, look, news flash,
you are paid to do that,
you cannot come to work and expect to do
what you are paid to do
and expect to become
an extremely valuable,
extremely important,
extremely appreciated asset
to a company, especially a growing company
that is moving forward, guess what?
You're going to have to do more
and nobody likes to hear that
because they think,
"Oh, that's more work."
Well hey look, look at it this way,
what you do and what you're
expected to do pays the bills,
what you do on top of that
and the investments you make at home
and reading personal development,
extra that you could bring to the company,
ideas, the extra things,
that's an investment in
your future, all right?
So, you have what pays the bills now
and then you have what's
going to pay the bills
20 years from now, all right?
And you have to think about that now
so that in 20 years from now,
you're not going back and saying,
"Man, I wish I would have done that,"
because that's something that
so many young people think
they got their $400 a month apartment,
they they go out on the weekends,
they've got wine, they've got beer,
they've got a little
weed and they smoke it,
and they think they got life made,
and the reality is is dude,
you do not have life made
because if you don't
put in the extra on top
of what is expected and
what you're paid to do,
you're going to be doing
that same when you're 40
because the myth that life is going
to automatically manifest
this whatever dream
that is you have is not going to happen.
You're not going to flip
the switch at 30 years old
and have the big hous,e nice
cars, and a fat bank account
just because you wished it.
You got to put in the work
now and network compounds
and accumulates and put you in a position
to have that opportunity
when you are of that age.
If you guys are 20 years
old and you're saying,
"Oh this guy's old and
he's blah blah blah,"
I'm talking out of experience.
This doesn't just happen.
So many of you young think
that this just happens.
You think, I'm going to show
up, I'm going to put in my time
and then I'm going to be rich
and I'm going to be balling like Rick Ross
you know and all these.
What happens?
You know what always
likely going to happen
with that attitude?
You're going to be 37 years
old living your mom's basement,
yelling at her for some meatloaf.
That's what's going to happen, all right?
So guys, you've got to do more,
you've got to become valuable,
you've got to understand
that what you get pay to do
is the minimum and
everything on top of that
is your investment in your future.
Once you're in the company
and once you're dedicating
your blood, sweat,
and tears and life to a company,
you have to be able to
evaluate whether or not
this company actually cares
about you or not, all right?
You've got to make that
decision on your own
and you've got to make the decision on
if they're telling the truth
and what's the easiest way
to tell someone's telling the truth?
Pay attention to their actions,
pay attention to their history.
Do they show a history of growth?
Do they show a history
of telling the truth?
Do they show a history of
taking care of their employees?
Or are they just blowing a
bunch of bullshit up your ass
so then get you in their system
for six years or a year or two years
and lets you just pour in
all your hard sweat labor?
'Cause I think that as a CEO,
this is this is something that
I feel like most employees
are concerned with and
what holds them back
from giving their all, okay,
and when you don't give your all,
it doesn't matter what position
or what company you're with,
you're not going to be successful
and what I see what I've
seen happen many, many times
is that people lose trust in a company
so they don't give their all
and then the company says,
"Hey, you're a worker,"
and then they get fired.
It's a vicious cycle that people get into
so what I'm trying to get
you guys to understand
is that if you're picking
the right company,
you should feel good about
going all-in for that company
knowing that in the next 10 to 15 years,
you're going to have a
legitimate, well-paying,
important, valuable part of that company
and if you're not, if you
don't see yourself doing that
in 10, 15 years with a company,
you're in the wrong company, all right?
I'm trying to get you to
avoid the vicious cycle
of being an employee that
goes every three years,
gets frustrated, and quits, all right?
Pick the right company from the get-go.
You can choose to either
accept that you lost
or you can choose to use
it as a lesson to improve.
Winners in life, people
who do well in life,
it's just like football when they lose,
when they get their butts
kicked like you guys did,
they say, "All right hey,
"look I didn't do as good
as I could have done.
"I didn't prepare properly.
"I didn't execute properly.
"I didn't run the place properly,"
and you know what, that's why we lost
but this week we're going to go ahead
and we're going to say, "All right,
"ABC, we're not going to do those things,"
we're going to prepare properly,
we're going to execute properly,
and we're not going to
give up early or ever.
If you guys want to be
great at what you do,
you have to understand that when you lose,
that's an opportunity to improve.
When things happen bad that's not the time
that you go sit over in the
corner, feel sorry for yourself,
make excuses as to why you lost,
you got to own the reasons that you lost.
You know what, I'm going to
tell you something right now.
You should quit and you
know what you should quit?
You should quit quitting, all right?
I want you to think about something
and I want you to think about
it in terms of your life.
Now, if you wanted to run a marathon
but every time you got frustrated,
every time you got tired,
every time you got winded,
every time you got sore, you turned around
and went back to the starting
line and started over
because you were all of these
things that are painful,
would you ever complete the
goal of running a marathon?
Of course not.
Guys, life is the same,
success is the same.
Nothing worthwhile is
going to be given to you,
it's going to be earned
and it's going to be earned
through your pain, through your misery,
through your suffering.
None of it's going to be easy guys
and the factor that separates
almost every single person in
life that's been successful
is people that succeed
quit quitting when things get hard.
Quitting is a habit, okay?
Quitting is a mentality,
it's a it's a core value
of people, all right?
They get a little bit down the road
and either they don't finish or they say,
"Man this is hard, I'm going
to try something else,"
or, "Man this is hard I'm
going to try doing this.
"This isn't for me because
it's hard, it's all hard."
That's what you don't understand.
Any path you take to get
where you want to be,
if that place is worth while
to go, it's going to be hard.
So quit judging, you're quitting
or you're wanting to do something else
based upon how far something is
because every single path
that you could possibly take
to get somewhere where you
want to be is going to be hard.
That's just a fact of
reality of this Earth
but that's what you have to understand.
Struggle, pain, misery, frustration,
those are signs and that
you are a, on the right path
and b, making progress.
You have to learn to identify
these things as indications
that you are on the right path, okay?
Nobody that is where you
want to be has gotten there
without these struggles,
without the bleeding,
without the pain, without the depression,
without the misery, nobody.
So, what makes you think
that you're going to be able
to be that person that gets
there with none of those things?
Guys, life is hard,
success is really hard.
and if you want to be something
big, you want to dream big,
you want to be something great,
you are going to have to
learn to accept that struggle
as part of the recipe, okay?
Every single day, you need to
look at yourself in the mirror
and ask yourself,
"What am I willing to
do to get what I want?
If the answer is whatever the I have to,
you'll probably get there in time
but if it's anything less, you won't,
and that's just the fact of life, guys.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Michael Bailey asked me to
so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I also love to know what did Andy say
that really inspired you, motivated you.
What did you take from this video
that you're going to apply to
your life or your business?
Leave it down the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Thank you again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
in whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- People start effing themselves.
All right, they say, "Oh
I got this great idea
"but what if I do all this
work and it doesn't work?
"What if I put in all this time
"to become an excellent employee
and I don't get promoted?
"What if I put in all this work
"to become an excellent
salesman and I don't sell?"
What if, what if, what if,
and I'll tell you what if.
What if you don't do,where
are you going to be?
'Cause it is going to be any better
than where you are now, all right?
It's very easy for people
who are in the beginning levels of success
or the beginning levels
of their success journey
to tell themselves stories
that other people's circumstances
are better than theirs,
that the other people have rich parents,
they've got luck, they've
got better circumstances,
they've got less obstacles,
and they say and I understand
that if you just do the
work, you'll get the result
but what if they want to believe it,
they want to succeed but
at the end of the day,
they don't do it
because they talk themselves
out of it, all right?
This is easily the number one thing
that keeps people from succeeding.
It's the number one thing that
keeps people where they are,
it's the number one thing
that keeps people broke,
it's the number one thing that
keeps people in a situation
of frustration or (clears throat)
basically regret and and
what ends up happening is
is that they end up
going through their life
accepting what they're dealt up,
doing what they're told and
they end up at 50,60 years old
wondering what happened.
Well, I'm going to tell you what happened.
You talked yourself out of going
after what you were supposed to go after.
You talked yourself out of your purpose,
you talked yourself out of the idea
that success is cause and effect,
not magic, luck, or magic fairy dust.
That's what happened and
that's the number one thing
that keeps people from succeeding.
It's the what if story
that they tell themselves
over and over and over again
as to why they can't move
forward and other people can.
Why if they do the work,
it still isn't going to work out.
Success is easy guys, it's easy.
It's making a plan and
executing the plan every day,
it's that easy, it's that easy, okay?
And people will be like,
"Andy, it's not that easy.
"There's got to be luck to it.
"My friend, he created the
super snuggie snowball machine
"and it made a hundred
million dollars in one day."
Well, you ain't your friend.
You're a regular dude just
like me and I'm telling you
and you could choose to believe
whatever you want to believe
but the reality is this.
Make a plan, work the plan,
make a plan, work the plan,
and whenever the plan doesn't
work, you change the plan.
That's called failure, it's
called learning the lessons,
called adjusting on the run.
You are not going to have
a perfect plan from start
to finish just because
you thought of an idea.
That's reality, so we talk
about the what if story
you're telling yourself the whatif story
you're trying to justify your fear with,
it's bull, it's bull.
If you do the work and you
do it for a long enough time
and you have at least
average intelligence,
you will be successful,
period, end of story.
Now, you can accept
that or you could go out
and you can look for all
the little exceptions.
You can look for the glory stories,
the guys who make millions
of dollars in one year
which they don't,
you know, it doesn't
happen to the average guy.
You go out there and
say, "Oh they got lucky.
"Look, that's all luck, it's all luck,"
or you can accept the fact that for people
who don't get lucky like us,
that there is a way to still do it
which is to make a plan
and execute the plan
and do that relentlessly consistently
over the course of 10 years
and you'll be where you
want to be, all right?
I'm a smart person, I'm
not overly intelligent,
I just make a list every
day and execute on it.
I don't worry about what if.
I don't think about what if I do this
and it doesn't work out the way I want?
I know that it'll work out in some way
and because I'm smart
enough to adjust the plan
on the way, I know that
it will at least end up
somewhere close to where I want to be.
It's not that hard.
We're over complicating
it, there are no what ifs.
If you do the work, the
result will be there, period.
Follow your passion and not chase money
and you'll hear people say
that and it doesn't make sense
because they think like it sounds like
such a like abstract thing,
like follow your passion.
it's like this like all
positive thinking mantra
or whatever but the
reality is is that business
is really, really, really, really hard
and if you're in business
and you're doing it
just for the money and you're not doing it
because you really care,
what's going to happen is
is when things get tough,
it's going to be easy for you to quit
because the money is
not enough reward, no.
It has to come down to doing something
that you're passionate about,
something that you love,
something that you that you want to get up
and do every day because that way,
when you're not making money
and the money's not there,
you still do it anyway
and you get better anyway,
so it makes it easier for you to continue
to get better and improve
which is what's required for you
to ultimately reach the goal.
So, I really think that
following a passion
is a requirement of being successful
for the simple fact that it makes it
almost impossible to quit.
So, try to figure out what
it is your passionate about,
what it is that you enjoy,
and you're going to
naturally become better,
you're going to naturally endure the times
of when it's hard because you love it.
But the thing is, guys,
you have to understand
that everybody up here,
puts other people first.
Everybody here teaches,
everybody here inspires.
It's not about me, okay?
That's why I see a lot of people
getting off track 'cause
I get asked all the time
and I've been asked a hundred times today.
"I want to build this business
or want to build a following.
"I want to do this, I want to do that."
It's very simple, make it
about the other person,
make it about what you can
give not what you take,
and everything else takes care of itself.